when you have a job that pays you enough
to cover your basic needs your bills and
even some more to spend the assumption
is that you'd be happy or even better
fulfilled and it feels and thinkable
when you wake up and say you're going to
leave a job like that to pursue a
passion and that was my dilemma six
years ago I had a comfortable job I
lived a comfortable life and people
expected me to be fulfilled but I wasn't
there was something in me that wanted
more
there was a misalignment between the
things I did on a daily basis and the
things that I deeply cared about and so
I decided to quit and explore the
possibility of bringing this passion
into my daily routines and I think about
finding your passion is that it's not
straightforward even for people with
money and degrees they still struggle to
identify their passion and here I was
either
fatiah old talking about finding my
passion and turning it into a career
literally people told me you don't talk
about passion until you've made enough
money or at least until you're ready to
retire because there's a notion that
looking inward and finding the things
that give us pleasure and fulfillment is
a luxury that only the rich can enjoy Oh
a pleasure that only the retired can
indulge in which made me wonder is
fashion only for the rich or an
experience only the retired can enjoy
for many of us we've been made to
believe that life is a race of survival
we've been conditioned to see ourselves
as survivors that must do everything in
our power to survive in Africa we're not
a to go through Scholl cram and pass in
the hope that you get a job after and if
you do stick at it no matter how much it
sucks
until you get a better offer or you're
asked to retire and as a dropout I knew
that I was not entitled to anything
every opportunity was a privilege and so
when I thought about quitting it was a
huge risk as given to alternatives which
are the most popular in Africa
the first one is sign up for any course
at a vocational institution and do it my
second option settle for any job offer
you can get no matter the working
conditions and do it that probably
explains why we have so many over young
people being trafficked in such of
greener pastures I opted for the fast
option I did look at a cup of vocational
institutions in the hope that I would
find a course that resonated with my
persona my dream and my aspiration as
disappointed to learn that there was no
room for misfits like me in these
institutions the education system in
many parts of the world has been
designed around pre-selected options
that young people are expected to fit in
or risk becoming misfits and so going
through school as nurtured and
conditioned to think in the straight
line and stay within the straight line
but when I dropped out I discovered a
world of possibilities I knew I could be
anything I could study anything
and so I leveraged free online courses
that's how I build my CV got into
employment and worked for eight years
and after eight years I told myself
there must be more to life than just
going through the routines of life so in
2014 I started an organization called
chiusa where we're working with other
school youth and empowering them to turn
their passions into profitable scalable
and sustainable businesses now when we
talk about passion one of the most
common questions that people ask is what
is passion how do I even find it and in
the simplest definition passion is a
collection of your life experiences that
give you the deepest sense of
fulfillment and to identify your passion
you need to look inward so we use two
reflective questions
first question we asked is if you had
all the time and the money in the world
what would you spend your time doing it
sounds like a very simple question but
many people struggle to answer this
question because they've just never
thought about it the second question you
asked is what makes you happy or gives
you the deepest sense of fulfillment now
you would assume that we all know what
makes us happy but it's also interesting
to note that so many people have no idea
what makes them happy because they are
so busy going through the routines of
life they have never stopped to look
inward and so identifying the things
that give us a deep sense of fulfillment
and the things that give us deep joy our
dots that begin to direct us in the
direction of our passion and just in
case you're wondering what your answers
are to those two questions I invited you
to sit with these questions later and
just reflect about it
however I am also aware that passion
alone cannot guarantee success in life
and I should note that not every passion
can become a career for passion to
become a career it must be covered with
the right set of skills conditioning and
positioning so when we get our young
people to look inward we also asked them
what skills do you have what talents do
you have what experience do you have
that you can use to build a niche in the
marketplace but more than that we also
look at the market trends because it
doesn't matter how much you love and
enjoy it if nobody wants it or is
willing to pay for it it can't be a
career it's just a hobby and the third
thing we look at is how do you position
yourself who are you targeting who do
you want to sell to why would they want
to buy from you and so the combination
of the three is what enables you move
from just a passion to a business and
many of our young people have been able
to turn their ideas and burning desires
into profitable businesses or social
enterprises and they're not just
creating jobs but they are solving
societal challenges I'll share with you
two examples one of them is Esther am
as the two years ago she had been out of
school for two years and had been deeply
affected by her dropping out as a reason
said experience severe depression to a
point where she attempted to take her
own life several times her friends and
family do you know what to do for her
they simply prayed for her when I met
Esther and I started to converse with
her I asked her a simple question I said
if you had all the time and the money in
the world what would you do without
thinking or hesitation her eyes lit up
and she began to tell me how she wanted
to change the lives of young people she
wanted to restore hope and dignity to
other teenagers by helping them make
informed decisions about life our sudden
of the fact that this burning desire in
her was unquenchable and so we worked
with Esther to put a framework around
this desire today she runs a social
enterprise in her village raising
awareness about substance abuse mental
health sexual reproductive health and is
helping other school dropouts acquire
vocational skills so they can make a
living for themselves it's that time 20
this year and for the last two years
she's organized an annual interest that
brings together over 500 teenagers
young people that are able to network
and collaborate on different projects
but more importantly to meet
professionals that otherwise never have
met this is all engineered by a girl
that believed the world had no room for
her that without education should never
amount to anything but by looking inward
and tapping into a burning desire
putting structure around it it has
become a model that not only changed her
life but is transforming the lives of
hundreds of young people every year my
other example is Musa Musa is a natural
artistic guy he's the time that we look
at any design and replicate it with ease
and so he sister recognized that ability
in him when I met Musa he was doing all
kinds of crafts bags belts wallets but
it was more of a part-time thing well
sometimes if it was really broke I
needed to make quick money then he'd
come up with a design and sell it but he
had never thought of it as a business we
started working with Musa helping him
shift his mindset from a hobby to a
business I'm beginning to rethink how
can you make products that he could sell
and even be able to scale Musa makes
some of the most amazing bags I've ever
seen and over the last one year musel's
business has grown he has been
recognized in different places currently
he's talking about exporting to
developed countries most unlike any
other drop out believe that without
academic credentials he wouldn't amount
to anything
he thought that talent he had was
nothing simply because he did not have
an academic paper to define him but by
looking inward and finding that what he
what I had was a greatest asset and
supporting him to turn it into a
business he's not just living his
thriving the thing about looking inward
is that it can be scary especially if
you're doing it for the first time but
the truth is you never truly start
living until you learn to live from the
inside out and in unlocking potential we
need to look inward to identify the
things that give us a deep sense of
fulfillment the things that give us a
deepest joy and then weave them into the
patterns of our daily routines
in so doing we cease to work and we
start to live and the thing about living
is that you never have to retire or to
resign and so as you think about
unlocking potential for ourselves for
iron people for our children let's not
conditioned them to look out one but
condition them to look inward to tap
into who they are and bring that self
into what they do every day when uses to
work and you live when passion becomes a
career you don't just excel you become
unstoppable
thank you
[Applause]